il est roi depuis un mois et 19 jours on
va parler de Charles III en Angleterre
alors pas avec lui bien sûr mais avec
l'auteur de sa première biographie en
français c'est l'heure de l'invité de
Paris direct
et Philippe Kail est notre invité
aujourd'hui bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous avez notamment travaillé
pour pour sa fondation pour ça de cet
homme qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le roi
Charles qui était alors le prince
Charles et vous êtes l'auteur de cette
biographie tout simplement intitulé
Charles III aux éditions Perrin qui sort
tout juste aujourd'hui c'est la première
biographie en français du nouveau roi
d'Angleterre
d'abord première question très rapide et
très simple est-ce qu'il est le dernier
roi du Royaume-Uni je pense je vais pas
pouvoir répondre à cette question je
suis pas de 1 mais je pense que il y a
beaucoup de défis qui attendent le
nouveau Royaume-Uni et je pense que son
le début de son quinquennat sera marqué
par un défi d'unité unité au sein de sa
famille d'abord on sait que Harry va
sortir
son autobiographie dans quelques
semaines c'est un problème qui persiste
avec Harry Mégane depuis quelques années
il y a sans doute de manière plus
importante il y a un défi d'unité au
sein du Royaume-Uni puisqu'on sait qu'il
y a des vellés des velléités
d'indépendance dans certaines des
nations notamment en Écosse et enfin un
défi d'unité pour le communal qui les
chefs du commonwalt et qui est aussi roi
dans 14 autres États à travers le monde
dont le Canada l'Australie la
Nouvelle-Zélande etc et des voix dans
ces pays commencent à demander à ce que
Charles le font le monarque britannique
ne soit plus le chef d'État dans ces
pays voilà l'abandon l'abandon c'est
allégeance à la couronne et notamment
beaucoup au Canada Charles il est prêt
depuis longtemps très longtemps en
France on débat de la retraite à 65 ans
lui il est en train de prendre ses
fonctions à 73 ans il a eu tant de se
préparer est-ce qu'on a une idée de ce à
quoi va ressembler son règne au type de
roi qui va être c'est c'est encore une
question difficile à répondre dans le
sens où il faut bien se rendre compte
que lorsque les Hébert iI est devenu
reine elle avait 25 ans donc elle
n'avait pas beaucoup d'années de vie
publique derrière elle alors que là
comme vous l'avez souligné Charles a 73
ans bientôt 74 et il a un demi siècle de
vie publique derrière lui donc on sait
comment était Charles en tant que Prince
de Galles on le sait provocateur on sait
les sujets qui l'anime l'écologie
l'architecture les jeunes la
régénération des quartiers urbains etc
et on sait que jusqu'à très récemment il
n'hésitait pas à dire ce qu'ils
pensaient mais là il a changé de rôle
exactement aujourd'hui il est le
monarque il a un devoir constitutionnel
de réserve et on a déjà vu il y a eu une
anecdote intéressante lorsque on sait
que Charles était invité à la cop27 le
mois prochain en Égypte il voulait s'y
rendre comme 27 un grand sujet sur
l'écologie sur lequel il s'est toujours
prononcé et engagé mais les stress lui a
dit non exactement et je pense que
les titres personnel je sais pas mais
j'imagine qu'il a dû être assez déçu
très déçu de pas pouvoir s'y rendre ça
aurait été son premier déplacement à
l'étranger ça aurait été symbolique ça
aurait été intéressant il serait su lui
a dit non il s'est rangé à la vie du
gouvernement c'est incroyable moi je ne
savais absolument pas qu'un premier
ministre britannique pouvait dicter au
roi ce qui pouvait faire ou non on peut
peut-être espérer que ça change avec
regisuna qu'on va voir comment ça va se
passer la Coop elle est elle est tout
juste là
d'ailleurs ce qu'on a aussi une idée de
ces rapports avec Richie soudain qu'on a
vu que c'était compliqué avec listraus
mais notamment au moment du dépôt de sa
démission là je sais pas si c'était
compliqué avec stress mais je d'ailleurs
les sur la cop27 je pense que il l'a
fait il sait que c'est son rôle de ce
qui est à la volonté du gouvernement
avec Richy sunac ça va être intéressant
les deux hommes se connaissent un peu
mais il faut rappeler que Richy sunac
qui n'est député que depuis 2015 il
était ministre de l'économie de à partir
de 2020
donc c'est intéressant et la photo de
Charles et de richesse unak
et pour moi était assez intéressant ce
qui m'a frappé c'est la différence d'âge
entre les deux hommes
comme vous le savez le Premier ministre
le plus jeune depuis 200 ans il a il a
42 ans et ça m'a frappé que richesse
Sina qui a plus ou moins le même âge que
que le fils aîné de Charles William le
prince de Galles et donc je me suis
demandé ce que Charles pourrait pas agir
un peu comme un mentor pour pour ce
premier ministre qui a 7 ans de vie
publique mais Charles en art un
demi-siècle donc est-ce que lorsqu'ils
vont se rencontrer toutes les semaines
il y a une réunion hebdomadaire entre le
roi et le Premier ministre et ce que il
pourra prodiguer ses conseils à ce jeune
premier ministre c'est intéressant parce
que Charles en tant que Prince il a eu
des rapports très troublé et on
l'apprend dans votre biographie avec
plusieurs premiers ministres notamment
Margaret Thatcher
très troublé je sais pas mais en tout
cas il n’hésitez pas à dire ce qu'il
pensait voilà sur dans les années 80 il
a beaucoup
œuvré notamment en faveur des jeunes
défavorisés en faveur de la régénération
des quartiers urbains c'était des sujets
sensibles à l'époque comme vous le savez
mais
Charles et le roi et politiquement
inclassable puisqu'on sait qu'il a eu
des des confrontations aussi avec Tony
Blair notamment sur la ruralité la
chasse à courre les OGM quand Tony Blair
a voulu autoriser la culture des OGM
Charles c'est opposé à lui donc si vous
voulez il a des sujets particuliers il a
des idées très arrêtés et il est dans
une position singulière qui lui permet
aussi de de parler au Premier ministre
et de faire savoir ce qu'ils pensent et
il a pas toujours eu bonne presse
d'ailleurs quand vous lui avez été
présenté d'ailleurs il vous a souhaité
bonne chance quand il a appris que vous
occupiez des relations presse de sa
fondation comment est-ce qu'il est perçu
par les par les Britanniques tout est
oublié tout est réglé les scandales
c'est derrière
je sais pas si tout est oublié mais je
pense que justement maintenant qu'il est
roi il ouvre une nouvelle page de sa vie
et je pense que l'émotion populaire
qu'il y a eu après la mort d'Elizabeth
II lui permet aussi d'être actuellement
dans une espèce d'état de grâce et je
trouve ça très intéressant les
Britanniques et l'accueil on voit les
foules très accueillants dans toutes les
nations d'ailleurs et aussi de manière
intéressante les Britanniques
accueillent aussi Kamila chose
importante il y a encore 20 ans
est-ce qu'il va jouer
davantage le rôle de passeur de relais
plutôt que que le même rôle que sa mère
c'est à dire que Elisabeth II a eu un
règne de 70 ans assez exceptionnel en
terme de durée lui on a 73 aujourd'hui
est-ce que finalement je n'avais pas que
ça principal fonction mais en tout cas
l'une de ces fonctions sera de jouer le
ce rôle de passeur de relais à William
qui lui pourrait régner longtemps c'est
pas ce à quoi il s'est préparé
évidemment ça fera partie de son rôle et
il aime son fils et il voudra voir son
fils
réussir et lui succéder mais il se
prépare depuis un demi-siècle à être roi
ça c'est certain il a des condoles et
des engagements il va certainement
vouloir peser et il va vouloir faire de
son règne justement pas seulement un
règne de transition on a un précédent le
Edouard VII qui était le fils de la
reine Victoria et également la reine
Victoria qui a fêté un jubilé de diamant
aussi 60 ans de règne
ce roi n'a rien qu'une dizaine d'années
et il a été un grand roi et il a
notamment été l'artisan de l'entente
cordiale justement la Première Guerre
mondiale qui était très importante et
évidemment pour rapprocher la France du
royaume et puis alors lui il avait
attendu très longtemps avoir des
fonctions officielles la reine Victoria
a bloqué jusqu'au bout alors que le roi
Charles lui il est préparé et il était
dans l'ombre d'Elizabeth II déjà depuis
une bonne dizaine d'années il occupait
déjà des fonctions officielles oui mais
ça il faut rendre hommage à la reine
Elizabeth je pense qu'elle a elle a eu
énormément de sagesse en associant comme
vous le dites depuis une dizaine
d'années Charles et dans une certaine
mesure William aussi à l'exercice du
pouvoir donc effectivement il était il
est plus que préparé j'ai une petite
question de la part de mes collègues en
régie qui regarde la série the crown
est-ce qu'il a vraiment essayé de
renversé Elisabeth II avec la complicité
de John Mayer je sais pas mais je pense
pas je pense que c'est bien que vous en
parler parce que je pense que c'est
réfuté par les auteurs de la série c'est
important de dire et de rappeler que de
quoi on est une fiction et si vous
voulez connaître la réalité des faits je
vous invite à lire mon livre exactement
biographie extrêmement complète sur
Charles III merci beaucoup Philippe Kail
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je
rappelle que cette biographie elle sort
tout juste aujourd'hui chez Perrin
biographie puis on se retrouvera
peut-être qui c'est le 6 mai prochain
puisque c'est la date du coursonnement
donc de ce nouveau roi d'Angleterre
merci d'être venu chez nous merci
beaucoup merci à vous d'avoir choisi
France 24 on se retrouve dans un instant
pour la suite de Paris direct à tout de
suite